area 15 got things rolling this weekend  to address  our nation's blood shortage today they  hosted a special  donate and skate event all donors  received a free ticket to its electro  roll pop-up roller rink sounds fun right  blood banks are still facing critical  shortages during the pandemic and  organizers say events like these  are really a fun way to help fight that  shortage it's important for our  community to give back  in the southwest alone we require 700  blood donors each day to donate blood to  meet the needs of hospital patients so  we're so excited that area 15  and vegas young professionals have  sponsored this amazing blood drive today  to give back to the community  if you're interested in donating blood  we've posted a link under this story on  our website  8newsnow.com